[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants alors nounours qu'il
est content oui patron j'ai une bonne
nouvelle je crois que le petit chemin
n'est plus un petit chien perdu je
descend vite vérifier si c'est bien lui
qu'on recherche dans ce journal mon
échelle au pont prolongé tellement
à l'eau sur la terre je suis bien
content de voir les petits enfants
[Musique]
il alerte reste coucou j'apporte une
bonne nouvelle
ni ne fixent caissière attentes et je
m'assois d'abord là comment se porte
notre petite amie chien
christ regardez ce journal je vous lis
ce qu'il ya d'écrit j'ai perdu pépito en
le promenant au jardin c'est un
ravissant petit chien très gentil sa
maman chien est très triste et moi aussi
si vous le trouvez
et si vous le ramenez je vous donnerai
tout mais bon
patricia
rue de grands peupliers pepito c'est
peut-être l'une
[Musique]
ses pépites au piton
puteaux
jeter un regard
ils rament et la can cet habitant mais
plutôt tu n'es plus un petit chat perdu
nous avons retrouvé ta famille mais il a
l'air content tepito
alors tu voles on a notre petite heure
oui nicolas mais je te promets que tu le
reverra t on très bientôt la rue des
grands peupliers n'est pas loin d'ici et
vous irez promener pépites au jardin
avec patricia
j'ai juré avec patricia tandis que moi
je mangerai les bonbons alors pépito tu
es prêt à partir homélie son beau
collier à temps je suis là dans ce joli
panneau avec une couverture pour qu'il
me prenne pas froid
non nous faire ses boîtes ont occupé on
répond je ne vais pas m'en occuper
c'est tout de même moi qui retrouvait sa
famille dont il est prêt
ne bougez pas des pictos soit sèche il
n'oublie pas ta balle allons en route
plus tôt
[Musique]
il avait vite vous coucher les enfants
bonne nuit
[Musique]
2 voilà bien chargé une ourse
le petit chien dans vous le ramenons
chez lui pas trop elle va être contente
patricia de retrouver son pépito en
route
pour la rue de grands peupliers dos nu
les enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents est faite de pur
[Musique]